[Musique]
bonjour ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de 7,8 échos le magazine
consacré à l'actualité économique de
notre territoire sans plus tarder voici
le sommaire
nous nous intéresserons aux nombreuses
opportunités qu'offre saint quentin en
yvelines en matière d'immobilier
d'entreprise philippe rayé président de
akira développement nous en dira plus
également sur les opérations de
réhabilitation miller de tertiaire que
sa société même sur notre territoire
dans ce numéro nous irons attraperont
vient de s'implanter une antenne de
positif planète association qui
accompagne gratuitement les personnes
dans leur projet de création
d'entreprise
enfin nous ferons un point sur le reste
de l'actualité économique avec notamment
l'arrivée de rethel m gallery by sofitel
à versailles ou encore le lancement du
club des entreprises de coignières mais
avant de développer tous et y trouveront
ce magazine avec un chiffre 3,7 millions
d'euros c'est le montant total des prêts
accordés par initiative sky depuis sa
création en 2009 initiative sky c'est un
dispositif proposé par l'incubateur de
saint quentin en yvelines le ski cube
il permet aux entreprises ont encore aux
porteurs de projets de prétendre un prêt
d'honneur sans intérêt entre 5000 et
75000 euros pour booster son activité
justement aider les porteurs de projets
à développer leur entreprise
c'est également l'objectif de
l'association positive planète présente
désormais sur notre territoire elle
s'adresse avant tout aux personnes
éloignées de l'emploi
reportage allez-vous je vends plus vous
allez bien
ça va merci accompagner gratuitement les
personnes dans leur projet de création
d'entreprise c'est la volonté de
l'antenne positif planète récemment
implanté attrape un suivi personnalisé
qui permet d'aider 200 personnes par an
on accompagne le créateur le futur
créateur important de projets comme on
aime dire de l'idée juste que
l'immatriculation et on fait aussi un
suivi post création on prend toutes les
activités qu'elle soit commerciale
artisanale libérale pour pouvoir lancer
sa société de navettes premium nadhem
bardy originaire de trappes a frappé à
la porte de positif planète donc m'ont
suggéré donc à un autre organisme qui
qui pourrait qu'ils financent sais pas
qui pourrait qui financent et grâce à
leur donc intervention j'ai eu le en
plus le plafond de ce cet organisme il
finance dieu dit milo pour l'association
ce dispositif d' aide à la création
d'entreprise permet l'insertion des
personnes les plus éloignées de l'emploi
l'implantation de trappes c'est vraiment
une un choix stratégique parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un taux de chômage
assez conséquente sur la ville de
trappes et le sud yvelines
et pour accompagner ces porteurs de
projets on a besoin d'être inventé sur
ce territoire
un soutien qui semble porter ses fruits
puisque 70 % des porteurs de projet vous
alors entrepris se développer à l'issue
des trois ans d'accompagnement
je vous propose à présent d'ouvrir notre
dossier thématique consacré à
l'immobilier d'entreprise sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
le 20 octobre dernier l'agglomération a
mis en avant ses forces lors d'une
matinée des changes au golf national
plus de précisions dans ce reportage
renault thalès ou encore airbus les
exemples ne manquent pas pour illustrer
l'immobilier d'entreprise sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
leader du marché de la grande couronne
devant marne-la-vallée cergy et vélizy
l'agglomération totalise 4 6 millions de
mètres carrés l'offre en immobilier
d'entreprise et répartir en bureau en
activité mixte ou encore en entrepôt et
logistique avec un taux de vacance
maîtrisé à 8,5 pour cent une trentaine
de projets sont en cours de
développement ce qui représente 250
mille mètres carrés un état des lieux
que l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a souhaité mettre en avant lors
d'une matinée des changes consacrée aux
opportunités sur le territoire de paris
saclay nous avons un certain nombre de
grands groupes déjà installées sur le
territoire qui confortent leur position
sur le territoire en regroupant d'autres
entités d'ailleurs ou des entreprises
qui se regroupent
mais surtout qui attire en fait des
bureaux d'études des sous traitants et
donc grâce à ça nous fidélisons
également les entreprises et surtout
nous conservons nos entreprises sur le
territoire et
nous essayons d'ouvrir à d'autres
entreprises extérieures au territoire
plus de 200 professionnels présents pour
cet objectif renforcer leurs
connaissances sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
dommage de la société que j'ai fait
conçoit et réalise des bâtiments
d'activités des bureaux clés en main
exemples de réalisations sur notre
territoire les entreprises antemeta et
asmodée l'attractivité du secteur de
saint quentin en yvelines était
socialement dû à la qualité des
entreprises qui sont installés mais
aussi au cadre de vie de saint quentin
en yvelines
la présence notamment de grands
équipements sportifs le vélodrome le
stade de golf avec l'accueil de la
prochaine ryder cup au mois d'octobre
2010 8 font de ce territoire pour nous
une source d'innovation une source
d'inspiration pour réaliser nos projets
immobiliers en lien avec les activités
proposées par le territoire une offre
immobilière diversifiée même si le
foncier commencent à se faire rares
face à cette situation l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines a la
solution
nous favorisons les opérations de
démolition reconstruction ou de
renouvellement et donc ça peut à la fois
un élément négatif mais un élément
positif puisque les immeubles qui sont
plutôt obsolète
du coup se reconstruisant si le bilan
pour l'année 2010 est encore en cours de
réalisation il prévoit d'ores et déjà
des chiffres record à ce jour entre 110
et 130 mille mètres carrés de
transactions implantation extensions
d'entreprises ont été réalisés et à
l'occasion de cet événement nous avons
rencontré le promoteur immobilier
philippe rey y est c'est le président
d'acs et haha développement il
intervient notamment sur notre
territoire dans le cadre d'opérations de
réhabilitation d'immeubles tertiaires
philippe rayé bonjour vous êtes le
président de akira développement l'heure
pour commencer ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter rapidement votre entreprise
alors à kara développant c'est souhaité
promotion
immobilière détecté il ya douzaine
d'années et on est spécialisée
en une entreprise et en résidentiel on a
deux départements on va à peu près 450
logements par an et on y voyait
entreprises on vise plutôt des
opérations clés en main on fait à peu
près 25 84 bureau parents ça dépend des
années et on intervient autant sur la
région parisienne que sur la province
lors un mot sur le marché de
l'immobilier d'entreprise puisque donc
vous le disiez c'est une de vos
activités
selon une étude publiée par le cabinet
géo immostat de ce marché serait en
train de s'essouffler mon île de france
l'investissement en immobilier
d'entreprise a atteint 4 milliards
d'euros au troisième trimestre de 2010
est ce qui représente une baisse d'à peu
près 30 2% par rapport au troisième
trimestre 2016 est ce que vous vous avez
ressenti cette cette baisse alors oui et
non non surement
pour le volet
locatifs de l'opération de conte à son
parent de saint quentin en yvelines
l'opération du carré non survolé locatif
puisque le locataire qui est un preneur
unique après la totalité de l'immeuble
n'a pas n'a pas senti ce ce
cette raréfaction ou certain
fléchissement de la demande contraire le
projet quand dès qu'on développe et est
un projet de grande qualité et qui
respectait parfaitement la fenêtre de
tir et de recherche de du locataire donc
de ce côté-là non sur le volet
investissement oui on l'a ressenti
on a ressenti qu'il y avait
malheureusement une remontée des taux on
était quand au monde sait que les
valeurs de vente baissent c'est
mécanique et je pense que c'est plus lié
à l'effet de stock
sur l'ensemble de la région parisienne
où il ya pas mal de stock
même si sur saint quentin en yvelines on
as un stock qui est réduit en d'avoir
cet ennemi passant de locaux vacants et
le stock fait que je pense les
investisseurs ont l'ont fait payer un
peu sur le projet
sur le projet notamment alors une de vos
spécialités c'est la réhabilitation des
immeubles tertiaires est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer en quoi ça
consiste
alors c'est une de nos spécialités
puisqu'on fond elle est aussi beaucoup
projets neufs
la restructuration du tertiaire ça passe
d'abord par la définition du programme
une fois qu'on a défini que l'immeuble
un potentiel de sur le marché pour être
rénové et remis sur le marché
on défile programme
de rénovation savoir à quel niveau de
confort et de performance l'immeuble
doit être remis qu'est ce qu'on doit
rien j'étais comme travaux pour que l'on
puisse de cet immeuble
une fois sur le marché soit compétitif
comme sur une valeur de l'immeuble de
neuf on travaille beaucoup sur des
opérations dans les secteurs prime donc
on vise toujours d'excellence
pour citer l'immeuble du carré l'ex
international
une image qui est assez parlant c'est
que on est dans les standards et le
confort des immeubles prime à la défense
mais avec des valeurs locatives
saint-quentin-en-yvelines rapidement
justement sur l'avancée de cet immeuble
alors le
nous avons acheté l'ensemble des
immeubles y compris son terrain parce
qu'il y avait un montage un peu complexe
en juin de cette année 2010 est
nous avons engagé les travaux sitôt
après on à l'immeuble a été vendu dans
la foulée et le maintenant cloué point
de l'enfer mais il est vendu et les
travaux de désamiantage curage ont
démarré dès mois de juillet
actuellement la moitié des immeubles et
déjà curé nettoyer et désamianté on
attaque la deuxième partie des travaux
lourds vont démarrer dès le mois de
novembre
prochainement et on vise une livraison
de la partie bureau enfin ensemble des
bureaux dont lé 28 mai clac bureau le
1er avril 2019 date précise et les
logements les 8 500 des quatre logements
seront livrés s'appuie mois plus tard
donc on vise également fin 2019
une dernière question est-ce que vous
avez d'autres projets à venir sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
oui on a d'autres projets en
restructuration donc un peu dans le même
montage que l'opération de
l'international à peu près dans le
secteur ce secteur c'est le premier pôle
historique darsières de la ville
nouvelle de 50 ans de jénine cas qui est
et qui a déjà 40 ans qui date de 40 ans
donc il faut désormais rajouter du
scandale du capex de 2 de la valeur ou
de restructurer l'ensemble des actifs et
donc il a il ya pas mal d'immeubles qui
ont été rénovés grâce à
la skip plus de ce qui est de la ville
de montigny et il ya encore un parc à
rénover en a quelques-uns on travaille
effectivement sur sur un sujet à bout ce
très beau sujet qui est très très
proches vous pouvez pas vous en dire
plus c'est au tour de la gâche menacée
j'espère qu'on sortira dans les mêmes
conditions que celles de l'international
merci fille priés d'être intervenu pour
c'est aussi un nouvel espace de
coworking à versailles ou encore un
hôtel quatre étoiles qui fait peau neuve
s'est tout de suite dans l'actualité
économique en bresse une ambiance
feutrée où s'allient l'ancien et le
moderne la marque mgallery by sofitel
vient d'inaugurer un nouvel
établissement à versailles l'hôtel le
louis versailles château intégralement
rénové propose 152 chambres dont cette
suite une salle de sport ou encore un
bar à l'esprit très versailles et l'idée
est de pouvoir apporter à notre
clientèle un service aux particuliers de
la personnalisation
ce qu'on peut appeler du cousu main en
tout cas c'est d'être le plus proche
possible de cette clientèle de connaître
leurs habitudes
et de pouvoir leur apporter une vraie
personnalisation de service le club des
entreprises de coignières a été lancé au
début du mois par l' agence pour la
promotion et le développement économique
de la ville
objectif fédérer les 800 enseignes de
coignières le principe c'est de réunir
les entreprises des représentants les
chefs d' agences les entrepreneurs les
directeurs de cette zone économique de
fer dure soit faire tout simplement du
réseau lan échanges de cartes travailler
dans une ambiance cocooning c'est le
pari du nouvel espace de coworking
pousse café à versailles wii fit
boissons fraîches café à volonté pour 3
euros 90 par heure l'établissement mis
sur cette économie collaborative un
espèce de con général prophétiquement
apparaît et un très peu en petite et
grande couronne donc déjà avancé pour un
petit peu mallet le plus le territoire
parce que je trouve que c'est un peu
dommage de pas offrir cet espace à des
des gens qui travaillent pas forcément à
paris qui n'est pas forcément à paris et
puis voilà c'est pour cette randonnée un
peu plus de
de nos tissus pour
agrémenter un peu le tissu économique
local voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi 14 novembre pour un nouveau 7,8
échos à très bientôt
[Musique]